Let's see if we can compare the mesh and the
bus throughput, for a small four core system, where the
traffic is evenly distributed so that each core sends a
quarter of all the messages in the system. And the messages
that each core sends are sent round-robin, to all the
other three cores. So if we are core 0, we send
messages to 1, then 2, then 3, then 1, then
2, then 3, etc. If we're core 2, then we send
to 0, 1, 3, 0, 1, 3, etc. And
you can assume that this is totally randomly distributed,
so that, we don't necessarily get any synchronicity among
these accesses, pretty much just like a third of
the traffic sent by each core goes to each
of the other core, but you can assume that,
it happens willy nilly. Each core, sends 10 million
messages per second. The bus, can support 20 million messages
messages per second, the mesh can support
20 million messages per second per link, and
obviously, the four core are going to saturate the
bandwidth, in which case they will have to
slow down proportionally so that. They match
the bandwidth of the bus. The question for
you is, the speed up achieved by switching to the mesh, from the bus is what?